If you want to hear about how all five Conjuring
movies to date are referenced in the trailer
for Annabelle Comes Home then make sure you
watch this whole video.
I called it!
Back in September I did a DeadTalk where I
speculated possible future Conjuring spin-offs.
This is what I had to say about Annabelle
3.
“So my guess is that Annabelle 3 will take
place while the Warrens are away on another
case, perhaps this takes place at the same
time as The Conjuring 3, and the film will
focus on Judy, or the nanny who takes care
of her, as horrors start to take place around
the house.
With Ed and Lorraine not there to help, Judy
may have to take on this entity on her own.”
Cut to: almost everything I just said being
true in the trailer.
Parents lock up the room, they say goodbye
to Judy because they’re going somewhere,
mistakes happen, and she says she sees things...
Wait, didn’t I also make a video last year
where I said they could do movies on the whole
room of cursed objects in the Warren’s home?
“But I think this room of trinkets is a
clever way to tie the series together, and
we may even see spin-offs of other objects
from this room.
I mean…
I know I’d watch a movie about this monkey.
Wouldn’t you?”
Cut back to the Annabelle Comes Home trailer.
The monkey moves!
OK, it’s not it’s own movie like I originally
said, but in a way, having a movie where all
the haunted objects interact could be even
better.
We may get a little glimpse into the history
of some of these objects, but we won’t get
beat down with a bunch of repetitive spin-offs
that simply go from object to object.
The only part of my prediction that may be
off, is where I said this could take place
at the same time as The Conjuring 3, because
I wasn’t expecting them to recast Judy with
a younger actress.
It looks like this takes place between The
Conjuring and The Conjuring 2, because in
this shot we see the music box from the first
Conjuring, and in the wide shot, you’ll
notice that the item Ed Warren places there
at the end of The Conjuring 2 is not there
yet.
We also see what looks like a genie lamp,
which reminds me of The Conjuring, where Ed
Warren explains that destroying the objects
would just unleash the spirit within them
and that sometimes it’s better to keep the
genie in the bottle.
"It's safer for these things to be in here
than out there.
It's kind of like keeping weapons off the
streets."
"Well why not just throw them in an incinerator?
Destroy em?"
"That would only destroy the vessel.
Sometimes it's better to keep the genie in
the bottle."
The rocking chair moving on it’s own is
a reminder of Judy’s first unpleasant experience
with Annabelle back in The Conjuring.
"Help!
Help!
Dad!"
"Get away from the door Judy!"
"Oh God!"
The windvane that moves on its own could tie
back into Annabelle Creation, which took place
on a farmhouse, but the big thing I noticed
here was this mannequin in the corner wearing
white robes.
The costume is somewhat similar to Sister
Irene’s white garb in The Nun, but it also
looks like there’s a veil, so maybe it’s
more of a wedding dress type thing.
That'll be something that we have to keep
an eye on when the movie comes out.
Father Gordon from The Conjuring 2 is seen
towards the beginning of the trailer blessing
the room of cursed objects, something that
Ed claims they do for protection back in the
first movie.
"Doesn't it worry you to have all these items?
Right in your home?"
"Oh that's why we have a priest who comes
by once a month to bless the room."
Then we’ve got the typewriter writing on
it’s own, where it says “miss me” over
and over, just like the three young people
from the opening sequence of The Conjuring
saw the same message appear on their ceiling.
Noticing a pattern yet?
A lot of callbacks to the first Conjuring.
Let’s add the Bathsheba ankle pulls in the
middle of the night, which also happens to
the young girls of the Perron family to that
list.
This demonic looking girl in the trailer seems
to be affected by the this projection cast
onto her, which is footage of one of the exorcisms
that Ed and Lorraine Warren use to teach about
what they do at the University.
Finally, we have the mystery of this little
girl.
“Can I play with Annabelle?”
“I think you have the wrong house, there’s
no Annabelle here.”
“The **** you say to me you little ****?!”
This is Bee, the little girl who died in Annabelle:
Creation who the demon that later went on
to possess the Annabelle doll was masquerading
as in order to trick the family into providing
her with a human vessel.
It looks like the demon is still using the
form of Bee in modern times, she’s even
still wearing the dress that Bee died in.
If you’re not up to date on all the Things
You Missed in the previous movie in the Conjuring
franchise, click the playlist on the left
to get up to speed on that.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week so you don't miss out on
the upcoming Things You Missed episodes on
Annabelle and Annabelle Creation, ring that
deathbell for notifications and I’ll see
you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.